in a nod to the relations between the
two countries that were once one Sudan's
newly appointed Prime Minister Abdullah
ham dog chose South Sudan's capital Juba
as his first foreign visit accompanied
by four ministers from his cabinet he
met his host South Sudan's President
Salva Kiir to mark the start of a
scheduled two-day visit as I promised in
my first visit outside Subhan will be to
do one and we are here today looking for
a very strategic very well home dog held
talks with his host his ministers met
their South Sudanese counterparts
topping the talks were economic and
trade ties South Sudan seceded in 2011
with most of Sudan's oil facilities they
once brought in more than 60 percent of
the country's revenues but Sudan's
pipelines and ports are needed to export
South Sudan's oil the two also share the
longest land border in Africa and parts
are yet to be formally demarcated more
than eight years after South Sudan's
independence that's caused tensions in
the past and was discussed in the talks
we have discussed many bilateral issues
concerning outstanding issues in the
peace agreement not the reason one but
the comprehensive peace agreement where
the issues of borders issues of
cooperations issues of economic and
political issues are still to be
discussed and those weren't the only
things brought up over the discussion
table the Prime Minister has repeatedly
stated he aims to achieve peace in
conflict areas within the first six
months of the transitional period on
Wednesday a coalition of Sudanese armed
group signed an agreement to start talks
with the Sudanese government mediated by
South Sudan and on Thursday ham dope met
with those groups to see how he can
achieve what he terms as his top
priority the armed groups had expressed
reservations to and some outright
projections of the agreement signed last
month that led to the creation of a
transitional government in Sudan and
while they have agreed to talks to end
conflicts they say achieving that will
not come easy
one of those challenges whether the
current government in khartoum has the
ability to overcome that the
constitutional difficulties the current
political setup has been designed by the
the constitutional text in a way that
put a lot of difficulties for the peace
process to voice mostly ham talk is only
starting his job as Prime Minister but
the country has been marked by conflict
and a troubled economy and it seems that
he's looking to Sudan southern neighbor
to help find some solutions for the
challenges he faces Heba morgen al
Jazeera Juba